do you think there's a way to tastefully
throat where it's not that used car
salesman helmet where it doesn't seem so
sleazy but then still getting word out
that hey alter egos is playing at that I
think oh but what I was in the only way
to tastefully self-promote i think is if
you make good work first and foremost
and you are legitimately proud of
something and then you are not a
reckless self-promoter to begin with if
you very rarely hit me up and go to lead
or text me or whatever that that one
moment when you do call me up and say
hey I made this thing I'm really proud
of it I would love for you to go see it
because I think you're going to really
enjoy it and I want people to see it I'm
really proud of this it means a lot to
me i would say wow okay great this is
obviously something that's really
important Joe and I'll go see it to me
the only way to really tastefully
promote is to very rarely self-promote
it's got to be it just has to be genuine
and and if you if you're convinced that
your every single droplet of sweat that
comes off of your body is brilliant and
and worth be inspecting under a
microscope I'm probably not going to be
on board when you when you you know
promote the one thing that's actually
really good yeah but I put up also I
mean to play devil's advocate i think
that you know if i have a twitter
account and i do I don't have many
followers but but if I were trying to
get in followers people that are
following my twitter account they are
specifically following it so that they
can get information they want to know
everything that I'm doing and you know
and you can make the information I give
a curl I give out can be you know just
like business like hey I've got this me
film a like I really like it here's a
clip from it here's an article you know
here's a link to a to an interview I did
and I thing people people that are
following me that's why they're
following day when I suunto say if you
do have a twitter account that basically
it's just and it's it's an arm of your
promotional machine yeah if i text you
you know i mean like we like if if i
text you that's annoying you're me
because then
just kind of like getting in your space
in your life I guess maybe I even
misunderstand what Twitter is even for
maybe that is what Twitter school it is
maybe we people are just expecting
Twitter to just be this kind of Mirage
of they are my table for specific
reasons and you can always unfollow
somebody right now so I so I'm following
you on twitter because I want you to be
tweeting things like hey guys new
television shows hey guys I'm on yes
suicide this week hey guys I body follow
like louis ck on twitter because he may
say hey a whole new batch of tickets
just opened up for the LA show you know
and I here's a link to go get him right
you know and then I'm like one of the
first you know I think that's it that's
the first information that's been put
out it's like instant instant
information I may not be properly
qualified to comment on Twitter then I
don't spend enough time on Twitter
dancin to really know what it's about
what if there comes a point in both your
career swear you'll be required to
divulge personal things social media as
a way of keeping people even more in the
loop about your brand that was the most
terrifying sentence I've ever heard in
my entire life I know that there were
words that you put together their know
they just I tuned out halfway through
and a sense of horror just invaded my
stomach we're not real so terrified I
need the cat can I hope you cuddled oh
my gosh thank you no one's gonna know
anything about you no one's gonna need
to know anything about you freed when
did you start sucking your thumb I have
about two weeks ago actually I haven't
recommended being really really look so
get out of it don't divulge that to
anyone
yep I tell you what there's a siren the
police are on their way
you